- Hey guys, just so everyone
knows, it's my dog's birthday.
(upbeat orchestral music)
Here at the Bean and Breakfast,
feeling happy.
Hashtag coffee first.
Hash tag I woke up like this.
- My man, can I get the sink?
- Service was a little slow.
Server could have smiled more.
Portions are a little small.
Overall, I wouldn't recommend it.
Check please.
Killer mustache, like.
Ironic road sign, like.
View of the sunset, like.
You like SunChips too?
Cool.
I'm requesting your friendship.
- Seriously?
- Yeah.
- That's my favorite too.
- Nice.
We should hang out sometime.
- We should totally hang out.
- Yeah, how about this Friday?
- Loving my caramel mocha skinny frap.
With almond milk.
Hashtag caffeine addict.